people's last days and
i'm just like oh i don't know
i don't know it's just happening
hogwarts will always be there to welcome
us home however there was a time when
the harry potter cast had to say goodbye
to hogwarts for good the deathly hallows
part 2 was dark and intense and you'll
soon find out that behind the scenes
wasn't much different we're uncovering
just how emotional surprising and of
course magical the final days on the set
of harry potter were yeah but i have
i've had a really nice time
needless to say the last day on set for
daniel radcliffe emma watson and rupert
grint was tense it also didn't help that
their last scene wasn't ideal sad right
the movie may have ended with the
beautiful epilogue on platform nine and
three quarters 19 years in the future
but for the golden trio their harry
potter journey ended surrounded by a
green screen while they continuously
jumped onto a mat it would turn into the
epic scene of their characters running
through the ministry of magic in the
final cut but as producer david barron
put it they took it in turns diving on
the crash mat and after two or three
times that was it that was the end of
harry potter all in all it was kind of
anticlimactic for a franchise that was
the exact opposite when cut was called
for the final time the three of them
broke down into tears it's not
surprising that daniel called the whole
ordeal bizarre um i was so upset on the
last day i really was
after they wrapped the three leads were
brought to a screen where they watched
an extremely emotional video that
production had put together there were
laughs hugs and some more tears but the
real heart-wrenching moment was when dan
gave this emotional goodbye speech i
love this place this has been my life
and so it's gonna be very very odd i
think for all of us if you thought your
life was completely changed when harry
potter came to an end imagine how they
were feeling at that moment we just hope
they had all the fun at their wrap party
that night it just always seemed such a
far away
thing really what's a party without
gifts right emma and dan 100 were not
ready for how bizarre their rap gift
from rupert was going to be as a tribute
to their 10 years as the most iconic
trio rupert gifted emma and dan wait for
it engraved trumpets yes like the
musical instrument he says he has no
idea why he just thought it'd be a good
idea
rupert gave me a trumpet which he had
self-engraved i don't play the trumpet
for daniel wrapping his time on harry
potter meant being extremely unsure of
his future after all at that time he had
spent more than half his life on that
warner brothers movie set like dan said
there'll never be a frame of any of
these films that i don't look at and
connect immediately to a memory he
always mentioned how much he'd actually
miss harry himself harry was like a best
friend to dan and we all know we never
forget a best friend stuff i got to do
in this part which which i
loved and will probably never have a
chance to do again emma's final days on
set had her reflecting on how grateful
she was to have the opportunity to star
in these films in the first place and be
able to play a character who was so
independent outspoken and smart from the
outgoing 11 year old auditioning in her
drama class to a household name she
truly believes they were all lucky
enough to be real-life chosen ones we
were the chosen ones yeah
rupert's goodbye to ron might have been
the hardest only because he said they
basically became one person take a
listen i'm gonna miss can't play wrong
but just like dan rupert struggled with
the fact that he wasn't entirely sure
what life was without ron and harry
potter but he still brought his iconic
ice cream truck to set on the last day
for everyone to enjoy it's kind of been
my life every day every hour so it's
what it's all been about and to not have
that anymore it's quite emotional tom
felton wasn't a part of the golden trio
but harry potter was in his life just as
long he was so grateful for everything
he got to learn in those years i've
grown up around some of these incredible
people um i've learned so much as an
actor his last day on sets consisted of
filming multiple endings for draco while
this scene where draco redeemed himself
by fighting with his schoolmates was cut
[ __ ]
tom was still proud of the development
he was able to give draco over the years
overall filming on the deathly hallows
part 2 was a great experience for tom he
even got to work alongside his then
girlfriend who starred as draco's future
wife astoria greengrass in the epilogue
i think in that respect we've learned a
lot and we've taken a lot from the place
it's it's only going to be positive
things really another longtime cast
member matthew lewis who played neville
longbottom also had the time of his life
bringing his character's transformation
to life his last day on set was spent
filming scenes of the battle of hogwarts
where neville became an integral part of
defeating the dark lord from an 11 year
old who lost his toad to an adult who
slayed nagini with the sword of
gryffindor he definitely got some of the
best development last ten years that
evolution of a character has been
incredible however we were shocked to
find out that neville's scene with
voldemort was the first time matthew had
ever spoken to rafe fines even though
they both starred in the franchise for
years that is alan and david thulis last
day on harry potter if you need proof
that alan rickman was wildly different
from professor snape here it is on his
last day on set he spent hours in his
trailer drinking tea and talking to the
younger cast members about what they
were planning to do with their careers
specifically matthew lewis who had been
scared of him for a decade but had
finally worked up the nerve to speak
with him you know it was because i was
terrified but you were incredible and i
just want to say thank you for allowing
me to work with you for 10 years apart
from giving advice to his younger
co-stars allen's last scenes were filmed
in the hogwarts great hall where he had
to duel with maggie smith also known as
professor mcgonagall he said it was one
of the most awkward scenes he'd ever had
to film because of the respect he had
for maggie but it had to be done
part of his final scene was actually
meant to be cut from the final films
until j.k rowling stepped in and saved
the moment by requesting all the battle
scenes stay true to the novels it was a
very changing thing of course as it
would be over 10 years all in all it was
an emotional few weeks as each cast
member reached their final days on set
of harry potter final bows hugs and
tears seemed to be the main theme behind
the scenes of the deathly hallows part
2. no matter how big or small their
roles were each actor played an integral
role in making the wizarding world as
amazing as it is going through her own
journey but very very much
her own self the truth is after a decade
of spending almost every day together
the cast and crew became one big family
they celebrated birthdays and holidays
together there was never a day on set
that went by where they didn't make
lasting memories with one another i
am still very much in touch with
everyone that i worked with the final
battle was the last scene a lot of the
cast filmed and was even where this
iconic cast photo was taken but just
listen to the cast explain how eerie it
was to be filming on the set of a
destroyed hogwarts with rubble and body
limbs scattered everywhere yeah it's
quite sad seeing it all smashed up
because we've kind of grown up here
the crew even ran into some problems
when they were destroying the hogwarts
set in preparation for the scenes the
set caught on fire and cost the studio
thousands of dollars talk about going
out with a bang
while filming the epilogue the studio
went through a lot to make sure no
paparazzi caught sight of the cast with
their aged makeup they had stand-ins
acting as dan emma and rupert who led
the public to an entirely different
place to where they were filming on
location
while it's been over a decade since the
cast spent their final days on set
they're still showing their love for the
franchise in a lot of ways all the proof
you need is in the cast fangirling over
the wizarding world at universal studios
here or one peek at tom felton's tick
tock at the end of the day the cast is
just like us people who fell in love
with a story about the boy who live
hey warner brothers we could use a
reboot right about now it's evident from
seeing these final days on set that a
huge part of the reason why the harry
potter franchise is so amazing was
because of how much love the cast had
for one another did you get emotional
alongside the cast while watching this